yeah getting your butt into the chair
your hands on the keys and seeing where
it goes I believe you have to have an
outline but then you got to like a throw
away that outline it will take paths of
a surprises to the the artist that
created it I've never known any buddy
who ever wrote anything that wasn't
surprised who wasn't surprised by lines
of dialogue that the characters seemed
to invent by themselves and twists and
turns in the story I remember asking
Neil Simon do you laugh at your own
jokes and he said sure I do the first
time I hear them and I think that's
fantastic that he actually hears them
it's as if somebody else is telling them
telling these jokes to him and that's
the experience I think of a lot of
artists it's not I wrote a Twilight I
sold a Twilight Zone episode years and
years ago about a muse it's some sort of
a composer of commercial jingles and his
muse and that proposes if I spare you
the story if I told you the story you
think hey what a good story but they the
thesis underneath it was the notion that
muses don't desert their artists it's
really the other way around you have to
be available it's never easy to get in
into and you have to own that you have
to know that I'm not sure that answers
what's the first thing you do usually
something occurs to you that seems kind
of odd you know imagine if this happened
oh that happened remember when my first
child was going to be born we went to
birth classes you know birth preparation
classes and which were held at
cedars-sinai and everybody was supposed
to bring a pillow so suddenly outside
you know the embed Lee Boulevard near
San Vicente what is this like all of
these couples all of the women are quite
pregnant and ever it is carrying pillows
you know what's that about
imagine you know you waiting you drive
past a bus stop and there's like 60
people at the bus stop and they all have
accordions
I don't know they've all got accordions
for some reason what could that be and
now and you start to think about that
and also you don't think about it you
just sort of like let it simmer and cook
and maybe a notion will come to you and
that you start to play with it and and
and see how it unfolds I know there are
other people including people you're
talking to I'm sure who have much more
precise steps I reject that in my own
work and in the work of the reticent I
know again I think that it's a function
of surprised a lot of our it is and the
the important thing for the artist is to
stay open to those surprises rather than
try to drag the narrative back to some
previous intellectual preconception that
you had very first script I ever wrote
and I never did sell it I wrote it in
class like my own class except it was
crosstown with Irwin or blacker
legendary teacher of screenwriting now
long deceased but he taught George and
Milius and all these people and I wrote
a story based loosely on an experience
that I had when I worked in the project
head start the pilot head start program
the war on poverty a Lyndon Johnson
program having to do with support for
preschoolers in the schools and there
was one social worker who a white guy
advantaged and privileged guy but he
kind of like would speak with a sort of
a fake black accent to Street he kind of
black jab you know hey bro what's going
on you know and he thought that that
really impressed the black kids he was
working with he was not working with
little kids and had started working with
adolescents in another program
and the establishment to people who ran
that program thought boy this guy really
goes the extra mile I thought he's an
idiot he's just patronizing and
condescending you know I'm a Jew imagine
somebody trying to make points with me
by speaking MIT I hear the shakes and
Noah Richard was real still you know
like I would think whoa what a what a
cool guy this is talks to talk well this
guy got killed he was murdered and I
looked at something to write a script
about when I wrote the script I thought
it was the social workers story the
white kids story but when I got done it
was really the black kids story and I
didn't realize that until I was known
with the first draft and the smartest
thing I did was to leave it alone in
that regard that is to say I rewrote it
several times but I let it become the
black kids story which is a much more
interesting story the white guy was a
subsidiary character now not the
protagonist of the piece I never sold
that script but I did get represent a
top representation I got assignments I
got on staff at Universal a lot of
writers don't get it that when a script
doesn't sell at something and it's just
the beginning there's all kinds of
rewards that can flow from the script
doesn't sell also script doesn't sell
now might sell you know down the line
Clint Eastwood made Unforgiven which won
the Oscar for Best Screenplay best movie
about 20 years after he acquired that
script yes so you never you never really
know but what was the point tomorrow uh
again if you if a first draft you put on
what you put into a first draft and you
end up realizing that the guy that you
thought was protagonist isn't the
protagonist is not a story about some
other that's not a waste that's not that
shouldn't be frustrating that's a really
good use of that draft you'll salvage
some of the stuff in the draft but also
you'll have used it to kind of point you
in the direction that you need to go you
can't figure it out in advance
you just can't Kushner at the Lincoln
screening have you seen it yeah maybe
you won't like it at all but I think
it's impossible not to be astonished by
how engaging it is an important it is in
the best sense of important
and and and it is a stupendous
screenplay by Cushing and Tony was
saying a lot of people think you think
the thing up in your head and then you
write it down but he says the writing
down of it is sort of the thinking of it
that there's a nexus between the pen or
the keyboard of hands on the keyboard
that kind of created and you just never
know and you have to live with that
uncertainty you have to sort of rejoice
in and celebrate and embrace that
uncertainty instead of trying to
eliminate the uncertainty you look at
the studio's today or and what's less
interesting than what they're doing now
they're doing prequels and sequels and
items of franchises what they're trying
to do is minimize risk they're trying to
make it so that when a audience goes to
see a movie they get what they expected
but when I go to the movies I don't want
to see what I expected I want my
expectations to be exceeded I want to be
turned upside down I want to be
frightened I wanted life to be changed
forever
so I I lectured September a year ago to
a an evangelical Christian conference in
Chicago 500 pastors from all across the
nation
on narrative in Scripture I was never
more warmly greeted or generously
received they also paid me very well but
I never had a better time you know I
mean I've given hundreds of speeches all
around the world I never had a better
time than I did in Chicago with all
these sweet Christians and one of the
things I told them was if you want to
keep people in the church you would have
to leave the church on Sunday morning
that is to say they should think about
the sermon if you want them just like it
if they'll leave your movie think about
am I still thinking about Lincoln I saw
it over a week ago and it's still
playing in my head and the more time
that passes the more I'm into it not
less it's not fading it's getting strong
I'll probably see it again the Oh what
is the point the oh the yeah the
Christians um if you want people say in
the movie just like if you want to see
in the church what I told them was you
don't need to make people feel good you
just have to make them feel scare them
half to death make them cry you know
imagine I remember walking out of a
theater in Westwood and the doors I was
walking down the street pass the theater
in the doors open people started to
stream out it had just broken and I saw
somebody I knew but there are a lot of
people between us and I sort of
indicated you know we were a high you
know and then I pointed to the marquee
and shrugged meaning to what you think
by this time he was able to get up to me
and he said oh it's a big good but too
worthy movie and I certainly think you
should see and I said um you know what I
said earlier like I you know this
doesn't make me very popular those
people when I tell them what they
thought of a movie well they tell me
what they thought of a movie night um no
that's not what you thought what you
thought was such and such I understand
that that's pretty arrogant um but what
kind of Kay I'm just reporting honestly
on what up on my own reaction and I said
to this guy you won't be surprised on so
you know what I hear you saying it's a
worthy moving but it seems like my
impression is you didn't like this movie
now I want you to imagine instead of the
the picture breaking and people steaming
energy but they're all crying everyone
is sobbing with straight tears streaming
down their faces um well you wouldn't
want to see that movie well yeah the
hell you wouldn't udemy dee Utley go to
see that movie it's top you'd stand up
your date your next appointment you get
in line to see that movie if it could
affect people so so strongly
you